[Música]
en la última jornada la o ms reporto 135
millones de nuevos positivos para kobe
19 en el planeta una cifra récord que
supera en un 40% la máxima anterior y
que evidencia los efectos de las nuevas
variantes del virus
dos ex editores arrestados en una redada
policial contra el medio es tan tenues
en hong kong fueron acusados formalmente
de sedición la publicación digital es la
única que aúne representa la crítica a
la china continental tenemos análisis
y comenzaron los homenajes de velación
del fallecido nobel de paz sudafricano
desmond tutu
sus restos mortales permanecerán en la
catedral de san jorge' hasta su funeral
e incineración el primero de enero
regresamos con ustedes y con la
actualización de las noticias en france
24 la organización mundial de la salud
de reportó en las últimas horas a algo
más de un millón 351 mil casos de kobe
19 en todo el planeta una cifra diaria
que pulveriza los registros hasta ahora
tomados durante dos años de pandemia y
que refleja la compleja situación
sanitaria a nivel global detrás de estas
cifras está la combinación de la
incidencia de las variantes de delta iv
o micrones de coronavirus nos amplia
álvaro cordero
más de un millón 351 mil casos de kobe
19 en un día en el planeta
esta cifra arrojada por la o ms nunca
antes se había registrado en dos años de
pandemia y refleja la alta incidencia
que está teniendo o micro una variante
mucho más contagiosa que las registradas
anteriormente sin que haya mermado la
temida delta delta en microonda artwin
trets delta yo me con son amenazas
gemelas que están elevando los casos a
cifras récord widget game lo que
nuevamente está provocando picos en las
hospitalizaciones y muertes antes
a miley cansan estoy muy preocupado de
que omicron al ser más transmisible
circular el mismo tiempo que delta ya
que está provocando un tsunami de casos
sliding de tsunami of case es esta ola
de contagios está afectando a todo el
mundo por igual en américa latina países
como argentina y bolivia han registrado
récords de casos en eeuu la realidad no
es mucho mejor ya que se estima que un
micrón es la variante dominante pero el
continente más afectado es europa donde
omicron ha emergido poco antes de las
navidades sin embargo aunque los casos
están muy elevados las restricciones han
vuelto de forma parcial y muchos no
creen que la situación sea peor que en
esto no tiene nada que ver con el año
pasado hace un sequía de caza flow
dormía
sabemos que hay casos que están
aumentando pero no nos damos cuenta
tratamos de vivir con normalidad claro
respetando las normas de salud pero esto
no nos impedirá vivir normalmente
esto se puede entender porque omicron a
pesar de ser extremadamente contagiosa
incluso entre gente vacunada
una tasa de mortalidad y hospitalización
menor que las otras variantes
desde este viernes será de nuevo
obligatorio el uso de mascarillas en las
calles de parís debido al aumento de
infecciones por kobe 19 la decisión se
produce después de que el primer
ministro francés hayan castex anunciará
al principio de esta semana
restricciones a las reuniones y
recomendaciones sobre el trabajo a
distancia en la última jornada se
reportaron 208 mil casos en el país por
otro lado los británicos que no sean
residentes de francia ya no podrán usar
el eurotúnel le bajó el canal de la
mancha para transitar por carretera
hacia territorio galo dado que ya no
forman parte de la unión europea
y tenemos noticias de hong kong dos ex
editores arrestados en una redada
policial contra el medio estancia news o
fueron acusados de delitos relacionados
con sedición aproximadamente 200
policías allanaron la oficina de la
publicación en línea congelaron sus
activos y arrestaron a siete personas
stand the news funciona desde 2014 como
un medio crítico de la china continental
si el gobierno de los eeuu no le teme a
la verdad y tiene confianza porque busca
la extradición de julian assange porque
nos trató a eduard snowden como un
denunciante eeuu debería abandonar la
hipocresía y la doble moral y dejar de
interferir en los asuntos internos de
china en nombre de la libertad twitter
snowdon para conversar sobre el tema
está en france 24 de manuel colombi y
directora de regional de reporteros sin
fronteras en américa latina' emanuele
gracias a usted 2021 fue un año de
cifras récord de encarcelamiento de
periodistas lo dijeron ustedes desde
reporteros sin fronteras es ser
periodista un riesgo natural de quien
nos protege
pues sí efectivamente
nunca desde la creación de nuestro
balance anual en
1995 tuvimos un número de periodistas
encarcelados tonales en 2021 tenemos
470 88 periodistas y colaboradores de
medios entre rejas para ejercer su
profesión lo que supone un aumento de
por lo menos 20 por ciento en un año y
esta subida excepcional de las
detenciones tiene que ver también con la
situación especial de tres países y
hermanas donde la junta militar retomar
el poder en febrero de este año pero
también en bielorrusia sumida en la
represión tras la reducción de xstrata
alexander lukachenko y la china de
exigen pin que ha intensificado también
su control sobre la región
administrativa de hong kong
antaño considerada como un modelo para
libertad de prensa en la zona así que
nuestros tres países tuvimos un aumento
significativo de las detenciones
arbitrarias de periodistas y
efectivamente a nivel mundial podemos
decir sí que es cada vez más complicado
más peligroso trabajar como como
periodista y esto en casi todos los
continentes infelizmente
bueno y que puede usted decir de las
declaraciones de beijing que acusa en
eeuu de tener doble moral al
solidarizarse con el medio hong kong s
pero al mismo tiempo procurar una
extradición del australiano julian
assange se pueden medir los dos casos
con la misma vara
pues si yo no voy a comentar
directamente esta declaración pero sobre
el caso de esther newsletter es
importante recordar sí que la mañana del
29 de diciembre seis miembros del equipo
actual y anterior del sitio de noticias
fueron detenidos y bajo la acusación de
conspiración para evitar complicaciones
deliciosas es un delito de la época
colonial que conlleva una pena máxima de
dos años de cárcel consideramos
gravísimo lo que está pasando en el
broker
exactamente seis meses después del
desmantelamiento del grupo next digital
y de su periódico estrella apple daily
podemos decir que la jefa del ejecutivo
de hong kong caridad vuelve a demostrar
su determinación de acabar totalmente
con la libertad de prensa en el
territorio eliminando de forma similar a
hasta en news esto es gravísimo lo que
está pasando y estamos a las democracias
como un todo a actuar de acuerdo con sus
propios valores y obligaciones ya
defender lo que queda de la prensa libre
en aún con antes de que el modelo chino
de control de la información se cobre
otra víctima es muy importante denunciar
en internet a nivel internacional lo que
está pasando en el congo está intentando
silenciar absolutamente todos los
periodistas independientes y esto es
gravísimo
gracias a usted continuamos con más
noticias los restos mortales del
arzobispo desmond tutu llegaron a ciudad
del cabo allí se celebran sus últimos
homenajes el ataúd del premio nobel de
la paz y héroe nacional que luchó por
acabar con el aparte y llevar la
democracia y la libertad a sudáfrica
permanecerá en la catedral de san jorge
hasta su funeral en incineración el
primero de enero
de vuelta a la ciudad del cabo en su
propia catedral el arzobispo desmond
tutu tendrá un último adiós en la misma
edificación religiosa donde lideró su
lucha contra el apartheid abogando por
la libertad la democracia y el amor
entre los sudafricanos
desde su fallecimiento el pasado fin de
semana a los 90 años la nación le ha
rendido tributo
líderes de una docena de religiones se
reunieron en un servicio interreligioso
el miércoles llamando a continuar el
legado de tolerancia del arzobispo tutú
y defendió la justicia e incluso después
de que recibiéramos la libertad ya sea
en el cine o cualquier partido político
cuando siente que se está haciendo mal
se levantó como un verdadero líder y eso
es el verdadero liderazgo
todos desde los residentes hasta el
alcalde de johannesburgo
compartieron su admiración por desmontó
y su viuda
solían compartir un plato de comida con
mi madre mantu tus solía venir a casa y
comer moregó con mi madre en realidad no
eran elevados no siempre fueron humildes
para mostrar su amor a la comunidad el
kobe 19 ha hecho imposible que las
multitudes se reúnan en ciudad del cabo
pero muchos acabarán a desmond tutu
desde cualquier lugar de sudáfrica y
finalizamos en brasil cientos de fieles
se reunieron en la emblemática playa de
copacabana en río de janeiro para rendir
homenaje a yemanjá la reina
afrobrasileña del mar cada año los
seguidores de la religión yoruba se
visten de blanco para celebrar a yemanjá
con flores cartas alcohol y productos de
belleza como obsequios o para la diosa a
quien piden bendiciones coincidiendo con
el cierre del año
sigue en france 24 y france24 puntocom
buenas tardes